the Joe Rogan experience and other
countries are aware of our freedom too
and I wonder how long they're gonna keep
the [ __ ] up in places like China I
wonder how long they gonna be able to do
that cuz like you see what's happening
in Hong Kong where Hong Kong is
rebelling against this I was there what
protests were happening we had to move
the hotel cuz it was like in this like
Civic area I think was like on Kowloon
Bay or something and I'll be a thousand
percent honest it was so congested and
busy there but if I didn't know there
were protests going on I wouldn't have
known it was and now it's probably grown
a lot but I mean it's ongoing those
people they got a message and they're
not backing down they're not backing
down what's incredible is it's been
going on for months and months and
months it's like new activity people are
just in the streets but a lot of people
have been shot on video you know by cops
and we just watch it I mean and it's
like it just happens and it's not a big
deal it's insane but we definitely have
these social liberties and and I don't
take it for granted and some of these
country and then part of me is like okay
some venues are big some venues are
small if I make a joke that you don't
like is that gonna be run up the
flagpole I don't want to take the chance
I know it's so interesting where it's
such a strange tipping point culturally
in this country and then worldwide you
know okay so what you know England just
had their big elections Jeremy Corbyn
lost but he did a video where he was
saying how he's running for president or
whatever it is Prime Minister what is it
over there
Prime Minister yeah I'm watching the
crown he said his [ __ ] pronouns he
said my pronouns are him he okay can I
just put this out there I'm super pro
trans I'm Pro fluid sexuality if you are
a straight male we know your [ __ ]
pronouns are him he well even if you're
a gay male you're a gay male your
pronouns are he/him too if your pronouns
are something or what it looks like you
are yeah I don't think you need that to
me that was very white night here he is
it's a hundred percent white nighty yeah
it was very cringy and I think a lot of
people like there's like some borderline
people like [ __ ] this guy with this he
am chef your pronoun I wanna say him
they Z whatever great he him when you
are when you're he him
everybody you know it's just such a
thing a ploy you know my pronouns are
he/him like oh no you didn't you [ __ ]
you're 60 years old because what is this
it gets other it's it's such a valid
thing for other people and then it makes
people I roll just a little bit and then
I think it takes away from the plight
the genuine laws of the trans community
yeah
which fully supportive of yeah if you
want to be called she or her fine I
again I'm not down with the made-up
words I end up words can all go [ __ ]
themselves the sir and zigs well also
you wouldn't know unless someone told
you like don't get mad at me for not
innately knowing that I should have said
you should have found Lee you should
have asked the pronouns no you got to
tell me no no you have to ask that's the
new rule you must comply
[Applause]